la visita de ambos mandatarios tanto el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin como el
presidente ucraniano boloñir selenski a
zona cercanas al frente de batalla llega
en el contexto de la pascua ortodoxa que
se celebró el pasado domingo y también
de la cercanías de la contraofensiva
programada por las fuerzas ucranianas
para retomar ese territorio ocupado por
las fuerzas rusas desde la invasión el
pasado 24 de febrero del año pasado en
cuanto al presidente se les que estuvo
en la población del Don vas de abdica
una población que como ha sido batmut
también está asediada por las fuerzas de
Moscú y allí se reunió no solamente con
comandantes sino también con La Tropa
que defiende esa población que es cada
vez más estratégica en esa lucha por la
región del Don Baz Y esa provincia
especialmente de dones abdica está muy
cerca de la capital de esta región que
está en control de las fuerzas
separatistas rusas y de los rusos desde
el 2014 desde entonces esa batalla
continúa en esa región y en cuanto al
presidente Vladimir Putin según se
conoció estuvo tanto en las regiones
ocupadas de Luján como en gerson en el
sur de Ucrania Allí se reunió ya no lo
vimos con tropas y no con sus
comandantes unas regiones estratégica
Allí se espera que haya bastante
confrontación en esta contraofensiva
allí los rusos tuvieron el control de la
capital de esta provincia la única
capital de provincia al control de Moscú
pero fueron expulsados a finales de
noviembre cuando gracias a la presión de
las fuerzas de kiev huyeron las fuerzas
rusas y se retiraron Al otro lado del
río allí discutió con los generales Cuál
será la estrategia de esa contraofensiva
y Cuál es la situación de las fuerzas
rusas a lo mismo que hizo ya cuando se
reunió con su gente en esta región del
Don base estratégica en la defensa del
país